if your usual breakfast is a sad
history with the fact that I feel sorry for
you son but don't worry because
I'm going to show you the Mexican breakfasts
that are the best in the world here in the
Mexican restaurant it is known for 24
hours we have more than 40  years preparing
these breakfasts in mexico we like to
have a very strong breakfast and not because it's chubby I
paint it badly these breakfasts are very
generous so that our people have
energy to work in the field
all day
today I am going to consume these excellent
eggs rancheros it is a typical dish
quintessential peasant this is the
energy bar of our people that
great nolan and that they mention that nothing
seems exquisite and it really is
but don't get confused they are
very humble ingredients from the beans and the
eggs and the pork rind that is made of pork skin
and of course the tortilla
[Music]
that we make them part about talking
I present to you the machaca ranchera this
typical dish from Sonora there  they
prepare it golden in the sun how clever
we are that we want nature to help us
get it out so we don't cook the
dry machaca food for cowboy
love is the tradition but here we
do it regularly with shredded meat
[Music]
we call this breakfast  poblano because it
has the typical mole poblano it has
Chinese of different types of chilies
sesame chocolate toasted bread tortillas
raisins but they put their soul and love
especially current from nopal to this
cactus leaf we take advantage of it
because life has to be removed from the thorns and
keep the good if you are
sweeter we have subscribers for breakfast 8
for fear and children with vices or
for customers the grinder we use
to remove the foam and make it more
cousins and richer regul
rly we sing chocolate with child
en is intended for  the martin
tobacco
[Music]
good appetite we are waiting for you